thanks guys i'm with fabiano caruana and
he's recognize this symbol over there
don't you I'm so Fabio welcome to the
show were you happy with your opening
today um I thought it's more or less
equal uh he seemed pretty well prepared
but I I think he has a simple way to
equalize and he started getting a bit
too um extravagant and he could have
played c6 early on and equalized and
then I was a bit better but um I'm not
sure if I hadn't ever had anything
serious so you're satisfied with her
play in today's game oh yeah maybe I had
chances to cause more problems but more
or less i think it was a normal game how
do you like playing in London uh yeah I
like it a lot uh played here a couple
times and I always enjoy staying the
city it's it's one of the most
interesting cities um and I usually have
a chance to go around and sightsee a
vegetable what's the one thing you like
to do if you have one afternoon owner
one night off in London what what site
saying uh I mean last year I would just
went around I saw Buckingham Palace um I
saw that I've London but I mean I don't
know if there's one thing that I do too
much to do probably I'm and Angela and
how does it feel the London chess
classic being part of the grand test or
what does that add to the event um well
there's the I mean there's added
importance of the the final standings
which I in all likelihood won't be a
part of but i think i still have my
chances um yeah so I mean it's just it's
interesting to see who will finish in
the top three overall who's your pick I
have to say myself I mean I don't have
many chances but if I do well here I I
can still finish in the top three right
that's right always got to keep the
confidence up right I mean after all you
just use one of the the Blitz Mac first
of one of the bastards um player in the
world icaro so feeling confident coming
into this right yeah I feel pretty good
about much houses all right thank you
fabiano caruana
back to you guys in the studio